a powerful story from attorney Sarah
Klein who as we mentioned is the first
known victim of Larry Nassar the former
USA Gymnastics and Michigan State
University Doctor Who was sentenced five
years ago today for sexually abusing his
young patients NASA of course will spend
the rest of his life in prison as a
result of those crimes and for our
series note to self Klein shares a
letter addressed to her younger self
about perseverance and how she later
took control of her own story
[Music]
hi little Sarah
life is good in Lansing Michigan where
kids play outside until it gets dark and
folks leave their doors unlocked
[Music]
you are eight years old
your smile is vibrant and you're still
working hard on losing those last few
baby teeth
you love School playing with your big
brother Aaron riding bikes and roller
skating
when the girl down the street invites
you to bring a friend day at the local
gymnastics Club you have so much fun
bouncing on the trampoline and
attempting cartwheels that you beg to
sign up for lessons
one day a man in his 20s named Larry
Nasser will volunteer as your team's
athletic trainer
young Larry will not yet have started
medical school at Michigan State
University nor traveled to the Olympic
Games as head doctor for Team USA
your coach John gedert will go on to
become the head coach of the Fierce Five
in the Olympics bringing home the gold
medal in 2012.
coach John will welcome Larry and set
him up in a back room
it is here that Larry will begin
medically treating you and many of the
other little girls in leotards
you will not understand that Larry's
treatment is not a legit medical
procedure but is in fact the sexual
abuse of a child
coach John will mentally and physically
break you down he will force you to
practice on broken bones
he will berate you and your teammates
Larry will play the good cop to coach
John's bad cop
when you are 12 and shaking because
coach John just pushed her face into
your own anxiety-induced puddle of vomit
Larry will be there with a warm hug
he will tell you he's got you
trust him and you will
[Music]
but your once bright and carefree smile
will fade
you will live in a state of fear and
Hyper vigilance as you get older you'll
hardly leave your apartment slipping
deeper into depression
[Music]
your body will begin to break down too
you'll be diagnosed with stage four
endometriosis and endure two complete
pelvic reconstructive surgeries
you'll still believe that coach John's
abuse was tough love and Larry adored
you protected you
[Music]
the next time you see Larry you'll be
standing in front of him in a court of
law
now with the word defendant attached to
his name
you and
155 others will deliver Victim Impact
statements as he is sentenced to up to
175 years in prison for sexually abusing
you and hundreds of little girls under
the guise of medical treatment
you'll walk up to that Podium determined
to confront your abuser but not ready to
show your face to the world you took
something from us that we will never
ever get back you will finally find your
voice
[Music]
you won't get the same closure with
Coach John
he will die by suicide on the day he's
charged with 24 counts of physically
emotionally and sexually abusing his
athletes
[Music]
when ESPN asks you to accept the 2018
Arthur Ashe award for courage you make
the bold and brave decision to come
forward publicly we're sacrificing
privacy we're being judged and
scrutinized and it's grueling and it's
painful but it is time
you no longer live in shame
thank you
now become the leading attorney in the
country representing survivors of sexual
abuse
you and your colleagues will recover
billions of dollars for your clients as
you take on high profile cases
you save lives
you'll appear on the hit docu-series
cheer what we're trying to do is tell
the truth and what we're trying to do is
keep children safe you will give a TED
Talk met with a standing ovation use and
trust your intuition and your story will
be featured in The New York Times
bestseller the gift of forgiveness
you will live and lawyer with love
[Music]
besides being an outspoken Advocate your
most important job is mother to two
little girls
the baby is two and her big sister is
seven
just a year shy of your age when you
first met Larry Nasser
and as she approaches the age your life
took its most difficult turn you will be
grateful you found purpose in your
suffering
kids will be safer because you exist
your kids will be safer because you
exist
you are changing the world for the
better sweet Sarah
One Survivor at a time
sweet Sarah indeed thank you Sarah thank
you she's gone through yeah so innocent
then what an experience yeah but like
she said what she went through is
helping others navigate yeah it really
is Saving Lives because she she exists
puts it in perspective when you look at
your own little girls Sarah Klein thank
you so much for that